junkies movie fights ah come on
movie fights is happening let's go all
happening to JT
why are you not in the booth what the
actual [ __ ] sometimes you got to step
out and show people what you're made of
how this is are you saying this is a
rudderless ship are we flying blind I'm
not gonna say a monkey could do my job
let somebody skilled can listen if you
put a thousand monkeys in the in a room
you could come out with the great
American you know what no thank you for
getting someone to take your place wow
what a fight we have for you today
- awesome competitors stepping into the
squared circle to throw down with
serious movie opinions and knowledge we
just talked to him
jte welcome to the show my man how's it
going I'm doing pretty good how I'm
excited for this it's been a while since
I've been in the ring you know I fought
this guy a few times usually behind the
scenes and backstage for the Snowdown
but I'm excited to take Jay Washington
he this man knows how to talk so I got
challenges yes he does yes he's a
stand-up comedian he knows his stuff he
knows how to talk ladies and gentlemen
yeah it was out of use his mouth runs
out with words and syllables Jay
Washington damn glad to have you here
and you weren't talking for a minute
Daryl no I had a tube in my throat uh
head was called a tracheostomy Thank You
Grey's Anatomy for teaching me that I
had a basically an abscessed eruption in
my throat had to have my neck drilled in
the drain out and then put a tube in my
throat for a week couldn't talk and a
lot of people who know me love that and
now I'm back talking and I'm gonna top
the hell of a lot of junk it's a little
man over here and go ahead and win this
moon fight I'm gonna wish a little man
we tell them to yeah you damn right I
said it already let's get this started
prequel wow man
shots fired early and often jte against
Jay Washington I kind of want to Apple
box
he might have been I'm standing on an
Apple box I've been referring to me as
little okay
we're both hey here's for the little men
but I'm glad I am not facing you today I
am merely judging and we have three
judges here's how this works I'm gonna
vote we have another vote and then
you're going to vote if the first two
votes are tied so besides my judging
vote another vote is going to come from
our fact checker extraordinaire which
today is mr. lawn Harris professor good
to have you
great to be here filling in once again
for long give me your thoughts on the
the owls the Guardians of Ga'Hoole love
those owls what are you you know that's
a better movie than you think it's gonna
be we make a lot of fun of it here on
the show it's actually a pretty well
done that's your story I would say lon
Harris always with a hot take thanks
brother and she is our resident queen of
social media please welcome our social
media ambassador Danielle Radford I feel
like I've never talked more about the
owls of ga'hoole that I have in the last
two weeks I'm wearing a pins your father
yes yeah I'm not always gone this is
what happens guys you leave from one
weekend we're gonna forget about yet
anything for soon anything your owl pin
yeah so just as a recap of how this is
going to work I represent y'all the
people the polls are on YouTube they are
not on Twitter they are on the YouTube
the pose will go up after the questions
have been asked if you're not seeing
them they're gonna be up in that little
I card if you're still not seeing it go
down
click the gear do annotations off and on
and essentially we are the tiebreaker
vote except for in the lightning round
where there are like no vodi votes so
it's just me and my opinions which is
where it gets scary Oh boobie I'll have
my own brain sometimes poopy and
you're gonna be reading out their tweets
maybe looking for a little bit of meme
action
I'm also on dink mean patrol thank you
just the dank ones just a dank one sorry
dank meme patrol so go ahead and go to
that hashtag hashtag movie fight slides
I am patrolling that I am also
patrolling my mentions I'm doing what I
can you guys I love you don't forget the
Cork's thank you for holding it down
Center some corgis alright very exciting
so again how this works we have two
fighters three first round regular
questions in the earlier rounds and then
when it goes to the speed round there
are four speed round questions so even
if the score is three zip after the
regular rounds always a chance of a
massive comeback in that speed round
fellas are you feeling it Jay you know
what I'm a waste ma waste on this so
let's get this over with real quick whoa
coming out of the geek hockey jte so mad
about mom I am very ready
I do realize well Danny was talking I'm
not a hundred percent sure I know what
dink means don't know what would you
like to take over the dank memes or
shall I
oh I mean we could tag team on it first
of all what does that mean I mean you've
never encountered dank when you've been
you know smoke a little that good good I
thought was when you missed a dunk you
helped this young man out
I'm the dank memes are the bestest that
freshest the hypest of the memes the
ones that are designed to make you laugh
make me laugh make the whole world sing
that's what then dank memes are y'all
yes thank you for that dictionary
definition of dankness now without
further ado Jonathan in the booth let's
see that sick ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a dig montage damn yeah you know
what Jonathan Jonathan's package is just
as nice as yours JT
question number one with a wrinkle in
time hitting theaters this weekend what
is the best fantasy movie aimed
primarily at kids what is the best
fantasy movie aimed primarily at kids
jte you're going first
so basically when I thought in this
question a lot of times it's the first
thing that comes to your mind
and it's something that's just
culturally relevant today so I really
immediately went to the Princess Bride
this is a movie that was not fully
beloved when it came out it wasn't like
this big box office hit people found it
and just started loving it the people
themselves championed this movie to be
the classic it is today and I think the
reason why it's the best the best by the
way I wanna really hit that word best
because there's a lot of good kid movies
out there my niece will watch boss baby
on repeat on Netflix all day that
doesn't mean this the best movie for me
the best movie has longevity quotable
lines and it's something that no matter
the age the gender that kid will sit
down and grab something from it and
maybe even learn a thing or two so for
me it is the Princess Bride jte going
with The Princess Bride Jay Washington
the question is what fantasy film is
most targeted towards kids and yet
Princess Bride is a good one but I
picked a film that is targeted to kids
and it's entire franchise is based being
targeted towards children and it's the
very first Spy Kids the story of two
kids who find out their parents are
spies and then have to become spies
themself to rescue them you have
children who have always pretended and
played to be spies so now to see this in
an action form in a movie it was just
brought to life on a grander scale again
this movie spawned three sequels after
that you bring up Princess Bride being
just a cult classic it didn't catch on
instantly Spy Kids did all right
fight it out gentlemen I think you
really hit the word targeted cuz I
definitely think Spy Kids is targeted
for kids
but there's nothing outside of that for
it like for me a good kids home the best
of fantasy filmed for kids is something
that stays with the kid for years and
years afterwards those sequels like I
never see anybody bring up Spy Kids just
anywhere it's just something does it
come up with film lovers or even like my
sister again I don't think she's ever
shown any of her kids my kids you know
I'm sure they would like it but I know
my sister who grew up loving the
Princess Bride will one day sit down and
show them the Princess Bride because
it's that beloved of a film Spy Kids is
something you could throw out if you
want distract your kids for like two
hours while you're doing something
cleaning up the house or just making
dinner you just basically answered my
own your own question you throw it in to
distract kids kids will watch spike not
when it's the bed and then they're the
best and something to watch the other
films following you get the Princess
Bride it's done you get Spy Kids whether
you order and I've you don't like it as
you're older you get spy kids your kids
are sitting here watching it they're
focused on it next thing you know you
got to grab the sequel you got to grab
3d game over you got to grab all this
not to mention people they fail past
just the original the main two
characters we didn't care that much
about they're Tonio ben and collagen
through the kids they've cared about
Carmen and juni carmen was 12 junior no
further [ __ ] damn right I did
the characters in that movie I doubt if
you were on the straw so when you say
targeted towards kids Spy Kids language
state all the way relevant for kids
there are various elements in the
Princess Bride that you're like oh if
you're a parent you pull back a bit
you're like oh when he brings out those
tender breasts or you might get eaten by
the eels different things like that pull
away every parent is not gonna allow
their child to watch The Princess Bride
it is easy for a parent to sit there and
say watch my kids and I don't have to
worry about a thing
I disagree that if you go back to
fairytales and even some of the older
Disney films they have some adult themes
to them they have things that push the
envelope a little bit that's not just
for little kids it's something that kids
will learn appreciate when they're older
for me this reason he was going older
but we're talking now put you looking
for their kids right but saying I
appreciate it when they're older so
you're saying they won't appreciate it
when they're watching again Risley kids
are watching transformers nowadays those
nice upright is nothing compared to some
of the movies are coming out nowadays
Transformers movies are based off
cocaine now
Oh every single one up but when you say
the presses ride you said it yourself in
your opening statement you didn't kick
it you didn't grab onto it right then
but you grabbed on to it later which Spy
Kids you gravitate to it now that's what
you want a film that's targeted towards
children for them to watch now not to
waste find your 1617 spy kids was that
film in the in the early 2000s again it
was such of targeted film that it
managed to spawn sequels
there are sequels because Rodriguez made
him on a very small budget that didn't
cause him honey the field review all
they had was a little bit we first since
you want to do that it was nominated for
different awards nominated for Best XI
fellows in a Saturn Award it actually
was not only for a Kids Choice Award
Kids Choice Awards we're talking about
the question is what movie is targeted
towards children yes doesn't matter
no that's the question this is a nest
targeted title dress is better targeting
film yeah Princess Bride is targeted
towards older people who go back to it
to revisit it as a cult classic you
cannot sit I have two children
it's called classic it was right before
your old navel sit down and yours my
kids before they watch birth you've got
a nice next one there will be t-shirts
with Princess Bride quotes across it is
hit pop culture this hit a level that
Spy Kids has never even come close to
region also it's the best fantasy film
because they're using talking so much
about spy kids and how good kids are my
daughter just called me right now my
four year old so let's let you know IRA
wants to provide will tell her daddy's
busy whooping on jte right now starting
off the ground and what would you say
start with J what would you say like the
wheelhouse target audience
age wise for your film is six 2/5 14 6
to 14 what would you say the wheelhouse
target audience for Princess Bride is I
would go 5 to any age above that because
it's a movie I believe you could watch
with your kids I am NOT gonna want to
watch Spy Kids with my kids
I am literally gonna do what he says
show it to them and leave the hell I
have the room
this Princess Bride has so many great
characters and moments and the fact that
uses these great tropes of fantasy film
a pirate there's a love story and also I
love the fact that Princess Bride gets
the gets the kids in the movies right
away because they are able to identify
with Ben savage because he doesn't want
to hear this story
he's like oz are kissing in this you
have the grandfather telling him a story
and they immediately are gonna be like
oh man that kid is me like he doesn't
want to
through this but yeah they're gonna get
captured by the story the characters the
action the romance there's a huge human
giant in this movie not a special effect
and that's a big thing I want to say uh
Princess Bride those effects
they never are like so overbearing we're
gonna be like oh man
20 years from now that's gonna look
pretty bad it holds up today because
everything's done practical and your
movie is so CGI heavy that 20 years from
now kids are gonna see it and be like
this looks like crap what am i watching
right now we'll be arguing different
films 20 years from now but the fact of
the matter remains you just said to bed
are you telling me Spy Kids defect still
hold up tonight say it still holds it at
that time you can see I can still put it
on but still have kids watch it my kids
particularly I'm gonna tell you
something my daughter is a handful yes I
love my look girl over to passion but I
will give a little ass a bowl of gummi
bears it's my kid and tell it leave
Danny the hell alone but you also just
said when people watch The Princess
Bride one of the things they say that
kid is me that kid is me is the same
thing you said when you saw Spy Kids
because kids have always played to being
spies and secret agents and doing
different mysteries and having to save
people and the fact that kid has to save
its parents is the great is a great
thing for children to be like I can be
the hero for mom and dad I said a mom
and dad had to be the hero for me next
question listen kids like a lot of
shitty movies as a kid I think about so
the movies I loved and I revisited I'm
like oh man that's bad that was not good
I should have never revisited this when
I showed kid The Princess Bride the best
fantasy film towards a child they're
gonna love that movie for generations
for their whole life it's not what else
moves you're ever gonna regret
revisiting is this something you're
gonna watch and they're gonna show their
kids for me Spy Kids it's just you watch
it and you're like oh this is ok as for
a kid but that kid is not gonna
appreciate me we've gone forward for me
the best fantasy film for our children
is something that's gonna last their
whole life one more thing I got one more
thing for you fellas I want you to look
into the camera pretend that camera is a
kid okay in your target wheelhouse age
and get that kid excited about your
movie alright jte you're up first
what's up buddy first of all
not my kid first of all put down that
Spy Kids DVD you got in a bargain bin
because that's trash we're gonna watch a
movie
that is gonna have pirates it's gonna
have Giants it's gonna have killer
rodents into the forest with freaking
flames there's gonna be a little bit of
love story but don't worry you're gonna
get through it and there's gonna be a
lot of laughs and there's nothing that
you're when your watches move you're
gonna be like that looks cheesy or corny
this is something you're gonna love for
the rest of your life this is something
that you'll be quoting for the rest of
your life and all your friends are gonna
be quoting put down that damn Spy Kids 2
& 3 because they're even worse than the
first one this is a movie that doesn't
need a sequel this is a movie that has
stood the test of time that you're gonna
love and if you don't I don't want to be
your parent I'm just yes you're not as
parent and no I'm keeping it real okay
or just frightening this child watch
that movie all right Thank You Jay te
Jay Washington here we go what's up man
look dad's watching for a second look
you've been bugging me about how you can
be the superhero how you can save daddy
and how you can save mommy even though
mom you don't need no save it but this
is what you can do I'm gonna let your
imagination run wild
okay you know how daddy bought you all
those little binoculars and watches and
walkie-talkies from Walgreens for $2 I'm
about to give you a movie that makes you
feel like you can use all of those to
save daddy and mommy
it's called Spy Kids now listen this is
a VHS because daddy don't have a DVD
okay so we don't put this in we've
cleaned the heads off with a q-tip and a
little bit of alcohol because we had
lost a lot of good tapes okay we still
trying to get the remnants a Total
Recall out of there but nonetheless
Danny wants you to watch Spy Kids and
guess what you're gonna be the hero you
and your imaginary big sister are gonna
do all these amazing things you're gonna
jump around you're gonna have explosions
and you're gonna be able to save mommy
and daddy and guess what you're gonna do
it again and again and again and if you
sit and watch this whole film daddy
promises you one big thing I scream that
he got off his EBT card because you are
worth
there's chocolate chip for 275 actually
274 cause it was on sale don't know
why's that number
but gonna watch Spike is now here's the
thing Princess Bride we're gonna watch
again kids asleep right now the kids
asleep watches a family later but you
gonna watch The Spy Kids because dad you
gotta take a nap alright time Wow
can I add my Princess Bride is a 4k
blu-ray remastered version okay not as
already time is already up first off I
would like to start a GoFundMe to get J
a DVD but here I scream I'm saying WOW
you guys what a matchup you came out
swinging and you know what jte you I
think you really laid out the argument
as to why Princess Bride is as a true
classic it has so much to appreciate but
then you know Jay took it back to the
actual verbiage in the question best
fantasy I know why is it primarily it
primarily aimed at kids good when I
asked you you said five two question
mark so there's a lot more ages in that
question mark zone then there is closer
to five zone so I don't feel like you
really were able to defend whether or
not your film was primarily aimed at
kids which is the actual question
because of that and Jay painted a decent
picture of Spy Kids
but I think the fatal blow was whether
or not yours is directed at kids and I
got to go
one for Jay Washington let's go to on
Harris was I'm in the world was was
transformers co-written by cocaine story
bike got it okay to get the story by
credit and then interestingly this was
not brought up so it doesn't count
towards the round but there is a spy
kids TV series coming late
this year to Netflix The Spy Kids
mission-critical which does kind of
indicate you know there is some lasting
interest in the Spy Kids franchise how
am I going to agree I think JT he picked
a much stronger movie and he did he made
a really good case that Princess Bride
if you were just apples to apples which
is the better movie I think JT you
convinced me that it's Princess Bride
but Jay did a really good job of going
back and saying is Princip right
primarily aimed at kids or ten kids
enjoy it and I think he sold me that
Princess Bride his name did everybody
and spike is is aimed at kids and so on
that level I think I got to go Jay as
well
BAM Jake Washington taking point numero
uno transcendent really took the best of
her let's talk to a transcendent woman
Daniel Radford tell us what's going on
on the YouTube okay well first we will
do the pull and the polls they do not
agree it's not super close is 58% for
Princess Bride 41% for Spy Kids one
really funny comment that we had and
also you guys there was a lot of love
for Harry Potter which a lot of girls
sent Harry Potter corgis a CEO somebody
to shout out for ASMR J which is what
you sounded like when you were talking
to your fake kid a lot of love for
willow but this comment stood out to me
in this comment on Twitter if I can oh
no did I lose it oh there it is it's by
Kyle
Nachi spelled na CH e who says finally
love for Spy Kids I mean what I what
other movie has a canon murdering uncle
named machete yeah it's real nice jte
well done Jay well done JT I can see the
community yes I also I gotta give some
love to Time Bandits oh I
I'm Time Bandits till I die Oh JT sorry
alright question number two question
number two what is the most badass scene
of all time from any movie this is an
impossible lesson how hard you know what
we're gonna do it we are making this
happen
Jay Washington kick it off my man this
was a difficult one because you're
talking about of any movie of any time
and one scene that I have to go to
consistently that will always stand out
to me is the opening scene in the very
first blade from the opening shots when
we see the dude he has his girl that
going into a party it's a rave party
going on all lights and everything it's
like it's a good scene then all of a
sudden things just change the sprinklers
just start coming down with blood and
you see the girl all of a sudden the
fangs appear and then next thing you
know the dude is freaking out but in the
corner we just start seeing blade and he
just started whooping all types of ass
and then you get that iconic scene in
the very beginning when he first throws
the like boomerang type blade around the
circle and just stands and smiles damn
yeah we saw a little bit as you were
talking the opening to the first blade
that's some badassery what kind of
badassery you got up your sleeve Jake
I've gone to the badass of the matrix
this was tough because there's a lot of
badass scenes of movies guys the go to
one scene
it's just it's difficult so I try to go
from my personal experience when I was
sitting in a movie theater and I just be
blown away like holy [ __ ] that was
awesome
for me it was the matrix and this moment
we're showing right now when he becomes
the one because everything in this movie
building up but everything was built up
to the fact that you do not mess with
the agents they are the badass mofos if
you see one you're supposed to do one
thing how run don't ever try to take on
an agent cuz they will take you out they
shown there's even a scene before this
where Keanu decides you know what bring
it on I'm gonna try to fight you and
he's like f no I gotta get the hell out
of here this guy can't be stopped so for
me watching that movie and then he
becomes the one first
he stops bullets in midair and then
picks one
like oh look at that piece of crap get
out of here then all sudden the freakin
agents are like what the hell no they
run right at him
was he do not only does he defeat the
most badass villains in this movie and I
would say of all films I think Agent
Smith is one of the best villains ever
he beats the guy with one hand behind
his back
you saw it he was doing this against the
bad guy the guy of the whole movie to
make that motion again alright find it
out gentlemen fight let's go your
argument was predicated more on the
agents in that kneel but remember when
we saw that scene in Blade it was the
first time we saw in action that quick
Wesley Snipes as the iconic daywalker
bro and we saw him kicking ass from the
beginning of the film not to mention the
cinematographer Theo van sandy who took
those shots took those elements of the
lights and everything that you see to
see the blood when it comes from the
sprinklers to watch the flickering
lights in the rave just changed all of a
sudden everybody becomes vampires and
one dude stuck in the middle like what
the hell did I get myself into then to
watch what's this like just started
cutting up and slashing people was
amazing what Keanu Reeves doing this it
was a dope saying because we've never
seen that before but if we were visit
that again we've seen it in 90 million
different movies the matrix things have
been done so many times and repeated so
often it's not even interesting anymore
you've also saw to an extent before it
was smaller but not as much but you see
me I'll just move I am the one all right
Keanu Reeves to an extent here I'm
insulting other characters I viewed have
said something about Morpheus more so
than Keanu Reeves out of road with you
but you know that's what you picked well
first of all mine is a culmination of a
whole movie with so many badass moments
that they had a top it with the most
badass your movies a great introduction
for a character but the problem is you
go back and watch that scene and it just
kind of has some of the cliches of a
90's action movie where a guy goes in
and there's 13 people around them and
one guy is doing this in the back but I
wasn't gonna jump in there soon as he
kills these next three guys I would jump
in and get hit you're going to the
culmination of that scene I told you the
whole is seen as an accomplice from
beginning to end again bad ass thing
this is an entire scene from walking and
the club nobody ever expected when you
saw him going to the club it's a
transition out the way it was you didn't
know he was with a girl who was about to
come a vampire you didn't know he's
gonna go into a rave that all of a
sudden that when the lights flickered on
the wall there was a sign in blood that
said bloodbath you didn't know there was
gonna be blood coming from how does that
make it so badass that's a good setting
of a scene again that's what makes the
scene great when it's setting its
setting is wonderful its lighting is
wonderful if everything is executed well
and then the combination to watch Wesley
Snipes in a row we've seen pictures and
teachers up we get that we get the I
kind of dropped Poe's later what he
calls the sunglasses but that's later in
the world that's how I bet I've seen the
G later in the film you're talking about
a later fella I'm talking my we set the
precedent of blade right there and knew
exactly what we were getting in that
opening scene is how badass is it it is
one of the greatest things because you
could keep remembering that saying
you'll be like y'all remember when the
duel was in there with the girl and all
the fans came yeah don't you be scared
to go to club right listen it's a great
it actually scene for Blaine okay yes
sir blues I never been to a rave in the
middle of a meat locker but Ellison
there's nothing badass about a rave
about some guy going to rave it is a
quarter duck scene you listen these are
great scenes I'm not gonna argue they're
not great scenes but we're talk about
the most badass somebody doing something
where you go holy [ __ ] I can't believe
is doing that those are some of the
weakest zombies I'm sorry zombies
basically zombies Dracula freakin
vampires I've ever seen they
disintegrate so easily so much so then
when they made a sequel they had
introduced a whole another kind of
vampire because they literally just like
they can't wait disintegrate you can
throw toothpicks of these guys there's
like those crappy effects to those
effects disintegration effect those
effects do not hold up when I watch the
most badass scene and I'm like oh that
looks like early 90s CGI that's and how
much does that saying hold up a blade
the fact that once we went through that
movie and even got through the horrible
blade Trinity six equal when they
started talking about bringing back
blade people want that same man to
reprise his role you know even though
there's fan are now people still want
Wesley Snipes to reprise his role as
blade okay so why you lose a good way
right but you wouldn't have that if his
scene would not have been so iconic and
so badass if he wouldn't have set the
precedent in the beginning of blade
one you wouldn't be talking about a
blood look we did a blade series with
sticky fingers and nobody gave okay
shout out to rest in peace spike us by
TV do anything bad ask for the rest of
that movie like this the whole movie was
on this one scene no it's a great
reduction for the rest of the movie that
has some really cool badass scenes you
know - Blaine you type in blade opening
scene they're almost six pages what I
was I don't know what else I was looking
at maybe not six about four or five
first like without the sequels better
than the first one in my opinion what so
there's some of these in the sequel
unless you have an epic first film okay
so I can go through the whole film
unless you have characters like Stephen
girl-talk Priscus Thompson Bush say
right let's you have what stop talking
about the trilogy and start talking
about the scenes that we chose from me
I'm about to see you're seeing that you
chose had to culminate had to keep the
key go to the key when we saw a first
sword Neil Neil was bland but when we
first see blade blade is kicking ass
there's the difference it took all this
time to finally to the movie for them to
believe you listen to get to be that
person his blade badass from the get-go
in that movie yeah of course he's blade
there's no backstory he's just blade for
me you watch the matrix you see a guy
who goes from an ordinary guy who thinks
he's working in an office who's bored
with his life to learning kung fu having
these epic gunfights and after seeing
all that you're like there's nothing
more badass this guy could do then he
reaches the next level they movie even
teaches you that he's not the one he
sees to Oracle she's like you know
you're not the one in my head I'm
watching the movie I'm like damn it he's
not the one this is gonna end and then
he dies I got a question for both you
guys so this is obviously what we're
doing here its objectives and like we're
judging in who swayed us to their
opinion but I would like to know the
foundation here I want to know your
definition of badass as we're asking it
okay um just in short
Jay what how are you defining badass
badass for me is a scene that sets you
up and you can't believe what you just
saw you're so encompassed in it and you
want to know what follows it cuz you're
like can it get better how good can it
get if this is what I'm seeing already
out eat whether it's in the beginning
middle and you're like this is what I'm
seeing already what are you gonna do
next that's what makes the scene badass
excellent Thank You JT what's what's
your definitely close we said but for me
the badass something just extremely
badass is something I don't see coming
something where I'm like oh okay
he's reached his level he's reached
level-10 he can't go any farther then he
does something so badass
he reaches another level of badassness
that I didn't know was possible and
that's what happened when I saw neo take
on a Jeff Smith when the greys villains
and movies with one hand behind his back
and starts to use the matrix he's
basically Superman meets God and when I
saw this I was like what is happening
he's a God in the matrix basically once
he becomes the one he literally becomes
the one time okay
wow what a battle I'm a little
disappointed no one mentioned the scene
where we meet the owls in the owls of
ga'hoole but that said you know what I'm
going to send this one over to lawn
Harris first yeah again I did not see
any there was not a lot of facts did not
see any factual errors though so that
that's good for everybody you know that
it was a tough it was a tough round I
thought both of them did a really good
job of sort of talk about why it's a
great movie why it's a bad I see why
it's a good like why they picked their
moment from the movie but I I was kind
of convinced I thought jte did a good
job of responding to everything that
sort of Jay was starting even I thought
Jays argument sort of eventually came
down to well you need the whole movie
the matrix leading into that scene to
make it badass but I don't think that
contradicts the question like well yeah
it's the most badass scene it comes at
the end of the movie you've built up the
agents is the sort of villain so I got
to give this one to Jay teeny boom
that's one for jte you know what I
thought jte really laid out some strong
medicine as far as why this is a pretty
badass scene but then Jay like was
coming with the fact that his scene was
so badass that he got afraid it was
going to start raining blood in the club
start going I'm looking up everything
but then when jte he laid out an
argument that I found unbeatable when he
just took us point by point how through
the movie there was so much badassery
and then they topped it at the end when
presented at me like that
that became unbeatable fatal blow I give
it to JT e JT e you take this point you
Danielle what's happening on the
internet there alright so as of right
now I have just done the thing so we
have God most badass the scene of all
time with 61% matrix neo versus agent
Smith 38% blade opening some of the
dankest things that I have seen yes
it's just like some really good opinions
a lot of votes for fury road different
scenes
I'll make the chase planned and Wonder
Woman got a lot of people digging way
back we got something else in film nerds
here yeah Hans Gruber's death got a lot
India in Indianapolis Indianapolis just
in do I know him look he worked on my
baby mamas car that was Joe
Beatrix fighting the crazy it's got a
bunch vs. Keith David and they lived had
a lot of votes with a lot of people
saying that it was so iconic it's been
parried a million times and then here
was a comment I really liked by at PLA
VI and OJ not gonna mess up your name
lady Blade exclamation points times like
5 just his description made me want to
watch it again side note I would like to
thank my mom for letting me watch this
movie when I was 11 years old good
parenting yes yeah yes it is good
parenting Oh lots of good choices
they're also not mentioned by Danielle
but probably a lot of tweeted by a lot
of people the owl's of Ga'Hoole alright
we are locked up at one that's a
stumbling-block ending i'm a fool for
google
all right we are locked up at one one
let's go to question number three
Oh what the crap it's a blind fight okay
go ahead and pick one pick one okay
let's go ahead and hear what your
choices are first and then I'll tell you
what the question is go ahead jte is a
crowd pleaser Manchester by the sea yeah
thank God Moneyball okay
Manchester by the sea Moneyball the
story of the Oakland Athletics in this
blind fight in honor of the movie
hurricane heist by the way I don't know
if anything should honor hurricane hice
but yes what movie would be most
improved by setting it in the middle of
a hurricane Oh
the honour of Hurricane heist you know I
just say in conjunction with the release
of hurricane highs because I don't feel
like we need to honor it yet there what
will you be most improved by setting it
in the middle of a hurricane jze round
number three you are going first for
Manchester by well first of all it's by
the sea so that gives me some points
right you can see a gun all right first
of all I measure by sea I'm going to use
the hurricane as a metaphor for what's
happening in our main characters soul
really we're talking about Casey Affleck
somebody who has to rustle spoilers you
guys haven't seen his movie the death of
his children that he caused he has this
inner turmoil that's eating him away and
slowly as the movie goes on it just
starts getting a darker and darker that
storms gonna come to a head and towards
the end of the film the hurricane hits
and so does Casey Affleck some ocean
these ripped out of him he can't taking
it he's drinking
he's fighting people in the bar the
family doesn't know what's going on with
him and the and he's got this kid his
brother just died and he wasn't told he
has to take care of this kid now I have
to survive a hurricane with him he has
to fulfill his dead brothers parentage
and take care of this poor kid he's like
and you know what happens this is what
happens when you're stuck in a house all
day there's a hurricane out there your
feelings come out you start talking
there's no electricity
you listen to the radio the Playstations
gone they literally have to deal with
each other's emotions they have to look
at each other with everything outside of
the blackened storms Hales running down
there like we just need to get into it
the storm has hit Manchester and it's by
the sea wow you just even fit the name
back in there Thank You JT j washington
we're talking about Casey Affleck soul
man for me the movie would be Moneyball
set to the bags robbed of the Oakland
Athletics there have a troubling season
Brad Pitt as they are trying to rebuild
this team trying to get them stronger
and the mist of their season now
there is an impending hurricane because
they are on the bay they are by the
ocean but no one no matter what the team
even though they're down even though
they're getting losing records and even
though they finally get Carlos pinger
they don't that the league is like you
guys can't play but they're like no we
won't let a hurricane stop us we are the
Oakland Athletics we will show what we
have and I'll keep talking to miss ASMR
voice we will show that we can win
throughout it all and they will keep
fighting and they'll keep clawing and
then at one point the hurricane makes
landfall and the league and the
officials in the stadium are iffy and
everything I like you guys got to stop
the game the game is over and the team
is like no and Brad Pitt's like damn and
no this is another Oscar I will sit here
and I will fight for this and at the
middle of once the hurricane hits the
outside of the stadium there is a grand
slam home run hit and while the winner
is running the bases the wind comes in
from the hurricane and takes his monkey
ass out and seem wow that's some high
drama all right I mean beautiful pitches
gentlemen fight it out a little bit
first of all they're gonna just bring
the turf out soon as I see cloud second
Oh KC athlete will be arrested now he
should be in their team wants to keep
playing where the visiting team is
visiting Wayne is there to work a
visiting team names like you know what
they're not going down without a fight
you know this team you know we're
revisiting the film it's five five ok
bases are almost loaded it's 3 2 on the
count two outs you know everybody wants
this ok but yours your film is dedicated
on this is his soul we're talk about a
tax for hurricane here brother
we're talking about winds up to a
hundred miles an hour we're talking
about it just ran coming we're talking
about people would die hard spirits just
sitting there in a green and yellow and
white jersey not giving up all of a
sudden for some reason journey is
playing in the background
you got a hurricane going don't stop
believing playing damn it this is money
ball money balls about brad pitt who's a
great general manager who was actually
able to make a great team
any journal manager that leaves his team
out there during a hurricane you're
immediately taken away with
character was all about this is all
about behind the scenes it's not about
baseball we are revisiting revisiting
this movie okay we are revisiting it is
not the exact we can't just take the
exact same plot it and a hurricane to a
baseball game
you got a Moneyball with just about a
scene you like of course I need it by my
movie literally hurricane as a metaphor
for sins oh did you understand how lost
you are when you took a metaphor a
hurricane literally sends with a storm
of frog hurricane it's a thematic with
the film it's very fits in with it like
a fantasy room okay we'll again who
knows that Brad Pitt wants his fantasy
Oscar okay
he's got baseball he's got hurricanes
davines Brad Pitt times all right you
know what I think we really heard always
[Music]
you know what Jay you know I was loving
that what you were I was picking up what
you were putting down man like them
playing in the midst of that crazy
storms it was right there by the bay you
even threw in some Carlos Pena you got
your like your 90s early 2000s baseball
player knowledge going but then jte like
you call him out for like yeah they're
gonna bring that tarp on the field the
first sign of rain and they are very
they're very trigger-happy with lego
rain delay will do it but then JT I'm a
little disappointed in you where are you
from what part of the country you
Connecticut you're from the New England
area and you've never seen Manchester by
the sea I have seen it I'm taking back
your Dunkin Donuts I totally
and from Dunkin Donuts for life you hand
me a jacket it's overrated but that
being said I think yeah you were talking
about hurricane you were like don't use
hurricane and I could picture that it
was you know Casey Affleck his character
did have to grow a little bit take care
of that kid and yeah I think that this
was neck and neck and I thought you both
had some fun here but I think jte edged
it out this was tough because I actually
thought they both did a really great job
of taking a hurricane and making it work
with this dramatic like what's already
going on in the movie and I thought that
that's not easy to do
great job on both fighters are doing
that I did when all was said and done I
felt like JT II had one really good
argument which is they forgot the tarp
well know that no I actually because I'm
like but I pointed out that Brad Pitt
it's about him being like a good manager
not necessarily about we're gonna be
like the toughest guys and push through
it's about we're gonna be the smartest
guys so I got to give it to GT BAM jte
takes it Danielle tell us about the
polls first of all I want to say that
I'm very happy that you used your one F
word for that
maybe you have to yeah so looking at the
polls the polls are saying Manchester by
the cs65
money ball 34 to go through some of the
great stuff you guys have sent me
someone said at clowny Jay said can we
add hurricane shame Helms - okay cool
corinne underscore w wrote the perfect
storm a movie about a ship trapped in a
hurricane that is also trapped within
another hurricane we got that cool yes
just a great just a great gift of a now
going through a storm
I thought hurricane season was over nice
Danielle do you think we properly
honored hurricane heist I don't think we
could ever properly honor hurricane no
we couldn't
we'll spend our entire lives trying to
do it I think we should do this every
bite let's shut up about hurricane heist
never it's two to one we're about to go
to the speed round but before we do that
we've been talking a lot about dieting
disaster films well uh made me start
thinking about disaster artists and
we've got we actually had the man the
myth the legend himself tommy wise oh
shoot some disastrous films with us
right here at screen junkies and it's
coming up this weekend take a little
peek at what kind of fun we have in
store oh my god it's a ladle whatever it
is
Wow there he was Tommy Wiseau with Bill
Paxton and knows that Jami Gertz yeah I
think yeah Jami Gertz let's get along I
can fact check that for me who's she and
check that out coming out this weekend
the disaster movie artist starring mr.
Tommy Wiseau himself all right fellas
speed round time it's 2 1 JT but it is
anyone's ballgame
we have four questions when I ask the
question the first one to speak will get
to go first
you'll have 20 seconds and then another
20 seconds of rebuttal two and then ten
second ten second okay twenty twenty ten
ten date day Washington you feeling this
mm-hmm JT e are you feeling it yes all
right let's do it
question number one The Sopranos is
getting a feature-length prequel what TV
show should be the next to get a prequel
movie quantum leap quantum leap JT
five four four and a half three let's go
with ask first Evil Dead ash vs. Evil
Dead all right we got quantum leap ash
vs. Evil Dead J Washington you spoke
first you go first
those who don't know the show quantum
leap is dr. Sam Beckett who travels
through time and he's hoping that each
mission each time his next leap will be
his leap home he is traveling through
time but you go back to the prequel
we'll find out how exactly Sam came up
with a theory
the quantum but relativity while he was
in school and also how did he meet his
best friend and time-traveling compadre
al we always want to know how did the
friendship between Dean Stockwell stop
it time all right JT so after an army of
Darkness there was like a 20-year gap
between the new TV series Astros Evil
Dead so let's fill in that gap with
Bruce Campbell awesomeness we'll bring
back same Sam Raimi well get something a
little bit different I love how they had
time-travel in the series let's do that
let's have them go to a different time
and actually kind of like Carly if
you'll be go on a bunch of different
time periods and facing Deadites taking
that chainsaw and killing some awesome
zombies wherever the hell they are
I'm you don't need to 20-year gap that
was between Evil Dead the National Evil
Dead that's the reason for adversity
evil day being brought back but what's
quantum leap there are a lot of stories
how does inky become Ziggy how did we
get the influence for that
how did he get the voice nobody wants a
quantum leap prequel no one really
remembers that show except for like
maybe my parents people in asked averse
evil dead is something that's current
and people that grow up with it will
love and there are stories to be told
between that gap where was the book at
the time Wow
gentlemen you brought it you both
brought it let's start with Daniel
Radford Danielle oh these are both
really good arguments I will say that
the while I appreciate Jays argument for
saying that like you want to see how the
friendship started and you want to see
Sam in school I don't want I mean I love
nerds but like if it's just a show about
some nerds in school working on math I
don't know if
going to be one can access to quantum
leap oh yeah 20 seconds I know it's not
that it wasn't a good argument it's just
you know you you pitched nerds um and
when with jte he says he wants to fill
in the gap between the movies in the
show I will say he says no one remembers
quantum leap I do I make quantum leap
references all the time all the time
it's a possum cult but I do like the
idea of having a gap bridged in between
the the new TV show in that so I'm gonna
go with JT boom one for JT with ash vs.
Evil Dead lawn Harris well I I really I
really disagree I mean I I do the J
pitched like kind of a nerdy kind of a
niche thing but I agreed with James
argument that there really isn't a need
to do another Evil Dead movie we we've
seen a bunch of them what JT pitched
sounded very much just like let's do
another Evil Dead the fact that it was a
prequel was kind of meaningless whereas
other J's pitch for quantumly fans such
as myself you really would be filling in
a lot of that backstory so I go with J
you know what man both great arguments
and jte you really like swayed me to
your argument when he talked about
filling in that gap but at the end of
the day I feel like we I'm thirsty for
that quantum leap and I think J gave me
enough interesting tidbits and for many
of the reasons that lon
spelled out I'm going with J and we are
all locked up if you want to see if you
want to read an interesting story go
down the rabbit hole and search the
court like them trying to make a quantum
leap movie and so y'all fascinating
stories so do a deep dive into that all
right listen all y'all it's a sabotage
round
to the Beastie Boys song Wow okay each
of you will pick your opponents answer
for the question and they must argue for
okay so take your time and then shout
out whoever whoever you think we have to
pick up here is the question
so what again whatever answer you say
goes your opponent gonna argue who what
actor should play a terminator in a
movie what actually terminator a
terminator movie thinking going on Kevin
James Polly sure
[Laughter]
so jte will be arguing for Kevin James
and J Washington will be arguing for
Paulie
sure have you ever done stand-up on the
same no and thank God okay since you
spoke first saying Kevin James that
means jte will go first 20 seconds on
the clock for jte will begin whenever
you speak Kevin James shows he'd be
physical like he's had movies like Regis
is breaking through walls he's literally
like a human Boulder that could just rip
through things he's a tank of a man so
for me he's like something I could be
intimidating if I see Kevin James
running at me or full speed I'm gonna
run the other way not a poly shorts
coming at me this guy can actually be a
scary force of just a robotic machine
that just breaks things time imagine
that iconic scene the portal opens up
and Pauly Shore is just sitting there
with his hair flowed out and look at a
bunch of dudes but next time some hi I'm
the whistle terminator where are you
have your clothes obviously I got a
fight sir Connor where is she and people
just want to shoot up a guy you're
shooting me why are you sitting with
bullet
it I'm a terminator it's just polished
ternary yeah sorry the Turner I supposed
to be somewhat intimidating nothing
about polish or disseminating especially
his voice Kevin James just has to be
silent look you even has the flattop
haircut that kind of Terminator had and
t2 he says a look at you Kevin James is
like a terminator is gonna have a heart
attack the moment he steps sideways like
there's nothing intimidated about Kevin
James that his blood pressure paulie's
short me run off you'll be like why is
this Terminator satellite robots don't
have heart attacks Wow all I know is we
just got pitched some mad Terminator
does a pretty good polish or I feel like
JT gave us more of why Kevin James would
be a good serviceable Terminator 2 movie
where his J kind of just gave us what it
would be like to see Paul eat or play
Terminator so I got to go JT on this one
one Oh Daniel I'm just gonna preface
this by saying that J I do want to see
your apology like I do want to see it
but I have to agree and honestly it was
kind of neck and neck with both of them
until JT he hit me with the robots don't
have heart attack it was it was an
impression that was good and a and you
saying the Kevin James is going to have
a heart attack that blood blood pressure
that Watson have heart attacks so I have
to go show you a tableau that robot
would there's her maid would be on
dialysis isn't that a philip k dick
novel robots don't have heart attacks
all right JD's Dream of Electric Hearts
yes JD gets the point it is now three
two okay this next question mr. Jane
Washington you got to get this otherwise
JD he is going home a champion today all
right here it is John Travolta is
starring in the first film from Limp
Bizkit frontman Fred Durst what this is
true this is a true story is true that's
really happening it's knackered it's
Fred Durst third film it's not his first
Wow okay thank you
what unlikely famous person should
become a director what unlikely famous
person should become a director
[Music]
Shawn wait Shawn white tiger woods
okay all right we we've both gone the
athlete route we got your wife a flying
tomato we got mr. Tiger Woods jte you
spoke first go for it
I grew up in the 80's 90's when they had
these really great movies that just took
place at ski resorts ski patrol ski ski
slope yeah Shawn white doing all the
schemes dug himself he got a cast of
people he gets friends in it he gets a
bunch of comedians it's basically an
updated version of those ski movies that
we used to love renting I'm J Tiger
Woods is a serious a serious individual
so him directing a film we get all
serious actors we would see him pull in
the middle streets to Tom Hanks to get
performances you wouldn't think of
oscar-worthy performances because he
would be so focused
you'd be like oh my god is this a
Spielberg type level actor he would get
De Niro he would be able to run his cell
run his show smoothly because Tiger B
listen this is what you need to do
target's life is a mess outside of the
golf course I don't want that guy on a
film set where there's who knows what
could be as disposal Shawn Blake
actually has fun yeah I feel like you
could bring that energy to movie and
have a fun time what director hasn't had
drama outside of her normal life on a
movie set but Tiger Woods to be serious
Shawn white all his movies would just be
skiing with Tiger we would get those
bodies of work that you would see that
would be drama be series becomes time
Wow yeah we know Tiger knows about
bodies of work
[Applause]
okay
you know what both had some interesting
points and arguments but I thought jte
you set up like the most fun vibe and
that makes sense for the characters so
for that reason I'm going with ski
school and Shaun White Daniel Radford oh
I hate this um I don't like the argument
about Tigers life being a mess that
isn't what but is that's not what it's
about because a lot of people's lives
are messes I do agree that Shaun White
is fun but I also do agree to go along
in line with Jays argument that Tiger
Woods is focused because if he wouldn't
his dad would hate him or whatever and
so the idea that he would put a lot of
his everything into doing that I'm gonna
give it to Jay for Tiger Woods all right
we are locked up at one one one Harris
yes sir
yeah well both interesting I'd like they
both seized on a really good argument
which is amazing I would do it cool like
hot dog the movie that's a great idea
but then Jay came with Tiger which has
that focus he has that discipline he's
gonna really take this seriously I
thought that was a really clever and
compelling argument Tiger Woods really
does have those kinds of connections he
plays celebrity golf tournaments he can
get in with those guys I feel like I
gotta go Jay so we got to keep going
when we're wrong bad we are going to
Game seven of the World Series aka the
last question of the speed round
gentlemen let me applaud both of you
first from making it to the end and this
is for all the marbles
what character should Finn end up with
in Star Wars what character should spin
end up with in Star Wars
characters are there besides any
character from that trilogy
well that was our bot that you work are
you talking like any movie kicker but in
that movie I'm gonna go with Captain
phasma well yep
Mauro's good all right we got rose
we got phasma jte you spoke first go for
it
so in the last time we sync every
peasant we think she dies but there's
always been this kind of chemistry
between Finn and her like when you hate
somebody that much it's not that hard
for it to turn to something a little
more maybe romantic so in the third film
she turns out to be alive and Finn who
was turned over from the Empire is able
to convince her to turn also she put
down those shields in the first movie
maybe she did it cuz subconsciously she
does want to be part of their part in
the last Jedi one of the things we saw
is the relationship any chemistry
beginning to happen with rose and fan we
saw them having bump hands and running
as we're back and forth and have those
little bump head moments an argument
those are the type of moments that lead
them to being together as a couple in a
relationship in a future film we're at
moment where he has to save her or more
so she saves him fully more than she was
she did in the actual film so why not
see them end up together and split off
with everybody I didn't reason Rosa's
arrest I saw it more as a crush like
he's a celebrity to her and I don't
think those are already ships I usually
work out for me it's more of a
fascination with him and that just I
don't see that chemistry I didn't think
they had chemistry in the movie I was
kind of like uh many people thought that
it was originally gonna be Finn and Rey
but to see the rolls to see the rolls
and Finn dichotomy happened to see the
crush happen to see that I'm enamored by
you and then go forward so watch Finn be
like I don't know but then being with
time oh man who is there love in the air
for Finn with who let's find out let's
talk too long Wow
tough tough rat I mean I thought Jay
picked a much more obvious answer
I thought JT got a good licking with
there well it's more like an infatuation
it's more like a crush but I really did
hear anything from DTE that would really
explain like how or why basment finding
but some mortal enemies the whole series
would actually get together it doesn't
seem very plausible to me and I don't
really feel like we heard a good case
for it so I'm going with J again alright
Danielle yeah push me to the edge yeah I
I do understand Jays argument however
jte had me when he mentioned it was the
thing of the the celeb crush versus the
Normie
I loved Rose I also agree that there was
not any chemistry with them after me so
I gotta go with the jte on this one all
to you man yeah this is possibly the
hardest decision I've ever had to make
you know what youyou really did have a
interesting tidbit there with like Oh
mortal enemies become mortally marital
embraced something yeah that that
evolution of that relationship but then
I felt J you did kind of pick the the
obvious answer but you summed it up
pretty succinctly that there's already a
little something there and there's
already that flirtation and that that
relationship that could plausibly go to
that next level and I didn't really hear
anything that would completely derail
that from you in regards I mean you said
okay he was she was like a fan it was an
infatuation there but I felt like that
argument was too strong
gotta go J Washington J Washington takes
the day
[Applause]
man you uh thank you for healing up and
coming in here and take a movie fights
my mama feels good to be uh which camera
my looking at cuz I don't know okay it
was just stand on how thank you it was
great it was fun coming in here yo
you're great fighters so I knew this was
gonna go down before I did also go this
closes water but man I'm glad it did so
I was happy to be here and glad to be
back in the building so hell yeah you
have anything you want to plug man make
sure you all if you're on in LA this
Friday tomorrow night catch me at the
Westside comedy theater at 8 p.m.
find me on Twitter and Instagram at mr.
Jay Washington and check out the trusty
sidekick podcast we just broke some dope
news on the trusty sidekick comm that
you all want to check out it's in
regards to Marvel's Avengers infinity
war yeah we're talking about beforehand
I won't spoil it but yeah good stuff
thank you sir jte always awesome to have
you and you took it to the limit I was
close man it was fun no I loved coming
on the show it's just so much fun that
when you'd fight some in those movies it
just makes that much funner I'll just
put my youtube-channel jte movie thinks
I do reviews spoiler reviews sometimes
Cheerilee reactions anything I just want
to talk about I throw it up there but
mainly reviews cuz I do can see someone
who's early if I'm lucky
thanks brother great having you oh let's
talk to lon one promising factual
information about where to find you and
what's going on with you find me on
Twitter at ello and as to find me on all
sorts of screen junkies fun follow us on
Facebook and watch our goofy videos
there hell yeah
Daniel Radford um yeah you can find me
at Daniel Radford on Twitter find me at
Danielle underscore Radford on Instagram
y'all are doing a really good job of
that keep fighting me I'm trying to get
that free stuff give me to that 10,000 I
want to sell some teeth whitening stuff
JT and Jay are obviously great fighters
I want to give it up to Jay for coming
out here even though his his neck still
has holes in it one I want to give it up
to GTE for adjusting cameras while the
Schuester I want to give it up to
Jonathan for also adjusting cameras
while the show was going Jonathan y'all
might have remembered was also here
during the early days of screen junkies
news it's really exciting give it up for
Joe stars laugh
give it up for the owls of ga'hoole and
the house
Thank You Danielle Radford I want to
thank you for watching movie fights
I want to thank Billy biz and Jonathan
and everybody that helps us pull this
together
thanks lon Danielle jte j washington and
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next time bye-bye
you